Carol tell me what it means to you to be
here tonight with a liar or topography
it means everything I mean it means the
brain is still with us which is the main
thing I mean because he narrates this
film and it's like yes he's still here
and the Pythons is still here we're all
still here and it is amazing it is
amazing after all these years is what 43
years and Python lives on and will
continue to live on so every time
something like this happens I was just
telling someone else and I always think
that every event is going to be the last
the last one we'll never get together
again for the fact that after 43 years
and and here we are here we are
no even these two gorgeous guys it I
don't know who they are it just just
followed me and it's great tell me what
memories you have in particular about
working with the pythons and of course
with Graham himself - well Graham was a
Graham was a very special person
he was extremely outrageous I I did find
it every now and then a little bit
awkward because he was so outrageous and
so outrageously gay that sometimes I
didn't know quite how to deal with it
but he was a very special very very
special person and very charming and and
even though I personally never felt I
got really close to Graham I know that
if there at the time if there was
someone I needed to talk to one of the
pythons who wondered that Graham would
be there he was just that sort of person
that would always be there for you what
you think makes the pythons and Graham
stand out so much why do we still love
him so much today because nothing has
changed based because the humor the
Python humor will never well will last
forever is classic and they're all
lovely guys and they don't change and
and the humor doesn't change the human
lives on always will I mean will will
always now in Python you favorite moment
from working with the pythons what would
it be well I got on very well with all
of them
I mean when I first joined the pythons
and I was very lucky girl because I I
was only supposed to be in four episodes
and it's down to them that I held on in
there I got on very well particularly
with John and and the to Terry's of
Micra on the beginning but and really I
can't say if I favorite moment because
every moment has been so wonderful and
when I think something is over and it
stopped like like working at the Royal
Albert Hall you know two and a half
years ago for the 40th anniversary I
mean that was a favorite moment I mean
on stage at the Royal Albert Hall and if
someone has said to me forty years
earlier when we were doing the
lumberjack song and if someone has said
when we did that you know 40 years from
now you'll be on stage or the Royal
Albert Hall
dressed in the same gingham dress with
your hair in bunches saying this
ridiculous line Oh Bevers I thought you
were so rugged and I would say no I
don't think so why would we be doing
that I mean it's amazing and that that
was a wonderful moment that was a
special moment is
and there and have 8,000 people cheering
40 to 40 years on you think wow well
you